I have never seen anything like what
families are going through now.
I don't know how they're going to cope.
I don't know how they're going to react
when there's no food in the fridge.
I don't know what they're going to do
when their children doesn't
have breakfast going to school.
We can very, very much
say that the cost of living crisis
has hit different parts
of the country very, very unequally.
Inflation has predominately affected
things which people
with lower incomes spend more on,
so that is things like energy and food.
The increased price of basic products
have made life very difficult for
the lower income bracket, or the lowest
20% to 40% of earners nationwide.
This is Nick de Stacpoole.
He is a single dad of three and lives
in housing provided
by the borough of Chelsea and Kensington.
He relies entirely on Universal Credit
for his income, which is paid out monthly
and provided by the government
for individuals
who are out of work
or living on a low income.
I'm looking for part-time work.
Because I take my two youngest
into primary school,
the earliest I could start
if I have a job in that area is 9:30am
and then I have to finish at 2:30pm
to collect them at 3:10pm.
So that is the problem.
In fact, I haven't come across any jobs
yet that are just those tight hours.
I don't have any family,
so I have no one to help me.
And the temporary work I'm applying for
is mostly close to minimum wage,
which is less than most of the childcare
in this borough.
For around a fifth of parents in the UK,
The UK is now one of the most expensive
countries for child care in the OECD.
So for those without a decent income,
there is no chance to pay for childcare
to be able to go and work.
So the Universal Credit, because
I have three children, I get top ups
so it's just over £1,000 a month,
which sounds quite a lot.
But, it soon goes
because I have the gas and electricity.
The gas, particularly
when it's cold, is costing a lot.
Now what I do is I turn the gas on and off.
In December, with gas
and electricity prices through the roof,
over 7 million
were going without basics
like food and heat.
And 4.7 million were
behind on their bills.
Food is crazily expensive.
For instance, the other day
we hadn't had ketchup for about a month,
but the children said “come on,
let's have ketchup again,
it's nice with the chips.”
The cheapest ketchup I could get was £4.50.
This is where Dads House
has really helped.
I go to lunch there once a week,
but also they have a food bank
that makes all the difference.
And Billy,
he was a single dad himself,
he set up this charity 15 years ago.
He really helps me
because he knows I've got three kids
and I haven't got any other help.
It’s a food bank.
It’s not just for single dads,
it’s for anyone in the community.
So, that's probably saving me £600 a month.
So that enables me to stay solvent, but
without that, well, our diet would suffer.
We've got roughly between 60,000
and 70,000 families registered.
We've got between 40 and 50 families
a day coming to Dads House.
The demand for the work
that we do went through the roof,
especially due to the cost of living.
And it's absolutely heartbreaking
when you see a mum or a dad
who is absolutely struggling
when it comes to not being
able to cook for their children.
of independent food banks say
they saw an increase in demand
compared to last year, and
reported supporting a significant number
of people needing help for the first time.
We can't plan. It's impossible
because we do not get
the financial donations that we did get.
And every day is really difficult
to maintain that level.
Sometimes we have
had to go into our reserves
to use that to buy food
and to provide small grants.
We struggle and it's heartbreaking
when you can't give to anyone.
So we'll go to the shops
and we'll buy food
and we'll go to the bank and take money
from the account so we can give that dad
a little bit of cash, so that he can go
and buy food
and he can put £50 in the electric.
When we can’t,
I can't sleep at night.
£1,254 for everything for a month.
Take off at least that £254 for travel.
I've got direct debits, which is £200.
So you're left with £200 a week.
So I take off
£50 a week for gas and electricity.
So if you buy no clothes,
no toiletries, no medical stuff,
no emergencies, no luxuries,
no birthday presents,
you're left with £150 for food.
And if you don't have access
to a food bank, that has got to last.
As I said before, if it wasn't
for the help I received from Dads House,
it would be extremely difficult
and their diet would be affected.
Universal Credit increased around
10% in spring to help with inflation.
Though this provided some relief,
the food insecurity of the past
year is why the UK's leading charities
such as the Trussell Trust are petitioning
for an Essentials Guarantee,
a way to avoid the increased poverty
and help with basic needs that benefits
couldn't cover for so many months.
They say the cost of living crisis has
exposed the erosion of UK's benefits system.
So I think what I'm hearing
when I'm speaking to people
is that there is support out there,
but it could be utilised a lot better.
When you talk to foodbanks,
people are really, really worried.
I have asked people repeatedly, like, when
do you think it's going to get better?
And there's just this bleak silence.
There’s this kind of question mark.
I'm incredibly grateful for
and appreciative
of what you do
get help with in this country.
What kind of helps keep you going?
My children.